sorry following this two billion dollar
Powerball you know my God everybody's
going to be a billionaire people are
buying tickets left and right well MIT
did a study and here's what they find
out the average lottery winner files
pink y
to five years why because the average
person doesn't know how to create wealth
generational wealth and secondly no one
has taught them how to keep their
generational wealth this isn't just
something that happens to lottery
winners this also happens to people that
make the money and don't know how to
keep in their families this is a topic
that's important to me because I got
four kids and I'm working on
generational walk down I want to pass
the generational walk down to my kids if
this is a topic that interests you click
on a link above or below come join me
for this webinar we're doing a research
on this entire subject here and it's
going to be limited seating if you
haven't yet registered click on a link
above or below I'll see you there